treatment options for cancer include
local therapies such as surgery and
radiation therapy and systemic therapies
such as chemotherapy and targeted
therapy you may receive one or a
combination of these treatments there
are several surgical options depending
on the type and stage of the cancer
during a wedge resection or segment
ectomy the tumor and a small margin of
healthy tissue are removed in a
lobectomy or sleeve lobectomy one lobe
of the lung is removed during a
pneumonectomy the surgeon removes the
entire lung in a sleeve resection a
diseased section of a large airway is
removed and the healthy ends are
reattached during any of these
procedures your surgeon may remove lymph
to check them for signs of cancer
radiation therapy or radiotherapy is a
local treatment that uses high-energy
rays to kill or shrink cancer cells to
relieve symptoms external beam radiation
therapy is directed at the cancers
location from a machine outside your
body
brachytherapy or internal radiation
therapy often in the form of pellets is
most commonly used to help relieve
blockage of the large Airways by cancer
chemotherapy is a systemic treatment
that uses drugs to stop the growth of
the cancer cells by either killing them
or inhibiting their cell division once
the drugs enter the bloodstream they can
travel and reach cancer cells throughout
the body targeted therapies are newer
cancer treatments that work by focusing
on specific genetic abnormalities of
cancer cells one targeted therapy
bevacizumab stars the tumor by stopping
it from creating a new blood supply
another targeted therapy erlotinib stops
tumor growth by blocking the chemicals
that signal the cancer cells to grow and
divide